okay there is a regular and constant
argument against increases to the
minimum wage typically from like the
supply-side economics types for the
people that at least think they
understand what that is if you pay more
it hurts employment you reduce the
number of jobs and eventually the total
demand for labor actually goes down and
you hurt the economy this is an argument
that doesn't make sense for a number of
reasons number one it leaves no room for
other variations in the labor force and
number two we've also seen anecdotally
that this doesn't actually happen we've
been covering what's been going on in
san francisco county california for
years now where they were way ahead of
the rest of the country in raising the
minimum wage they're above and beyond uh
even what what many states currently
have is the minimum wage they were years
ahead of it this applied also to fast
food which is one of those industries
that's often sort of considered to be as
soon as you raise minimum wage it really
hurts fast-food employees and fast food
restaurants no negative repercussions
now you could still say well okay David
fine it's not true that necessarily you
hurt jobs by raising the minimum wage
and it's not true that necessarily
raising the minimum wage hurts fast food
but that's just San Francisco San
Francisco is a very high income area
it's a very unique situation where it's
a high cost of living but also very very
wealthy area you need to look elsewhere
well fortunately for us that's exactly
what the Center for Economic and Policy
Research did they analyzed a report by
the White House Council of Economic
Advisers on the effects of raising the
minimum wage beyond the federal minimum
okay so they say okay here is where we
are based on the federal minimum wage of
725 let's see what impact unemployment
in the economy going beyond that federal
minimum has the researchers found that
the 18 states plus Washington DC that
increased wages beyond the federal
minimum wage in 2014 number one it led
to low income workers benefiting that
obviously makes sense
but it also saw no uh-uh depression of
jobs available to low-income workers
there was no additional economic harm uh
found to those increases above and
beyond the federal minimum wage this
actually increased average wages in
low-wage jobs but it also reversed a
trend generally of falling real wages
that we saw and we did not see a
negative impact on jobs the CEA for
those who say hey it's a white House
Counsel the CEA doesn't have its own
data they use Bureau of Labor Statistics
data from for workers and leisure and
hospitality and I've talked many times
before if you don't believe the Bureau
of Labor Statistics data under President
Obama then you actually can't really
argue that unemployment is high or low
because it's all being compared to
Bureau of Labor Statistics data under
other presidents and it's very hard to
argue that only under President Obama is
that data not trustworthy so those who
argue against for example safety net
programs or raising the minimum wage or
having a basic income they often go
beyond the economic argument many of
them say the problem David is not the
economic argument fine maybe these
programs raising the minimum wage
welfare programs it's not bad for the
economy but we can't just be handing
things out to people and this gets us
back to this concept which George Lake
off talked about quite a bit of strict
father morality which is when as
progressives we identify a Republican
position we analyze it and we say hey
you know what it turns out that even
though Republicans say they're concerned
with fiscal conservatism they support a
policy that is not fiscally conservative
or it's not pro-business layer two is
fundamentally strict father morality and
the idea of people only having what they
quote deserve according to conservatives
will actually override the supposedly
important principle of fiscal
conservative conservatism and making
good economic decisions last thing on
this
uh anytime we talk about raising the
minimum wage some people will write into
me and I'll say David if raising the
minimum wage is good just raise it to
200 bucks an hour then everybody will
have tons of money do not fall for that
red herring that red herring ignores
that no one is calling for raising the
minimum wage to two hundred dollars an
hour when we talk about twelve fifteen
or eighteen dollars an hour we're
talking about minimum wages in a range
that can be justified by changes to cost
of living and increases in productivity
and what it takes to earn a living wage
in different parts of the United States
that is what is called uh reductio ad
absurdum when you say well if it's good
to raise it from twelve to thirteen
raising it to 200 must be really good no
no one is arguing that that is what
should be done no serious economist are
saying that you have to base the minimum
wage on the economic realities of a
living wage and what would be an
equilibrium wage in our economy uh the
two hundred dollar minimum wage red
herring you have to be ready to debunk
that because it makes absolutely no
sense whatsoever let's take a break
still plenty more coming up glad you're
with me on this Thursday thanks for
watching this video before you watch the
next one remember we're raising money to
expand the david pakman show big league
as well as expand progressive activism
go to david pakman.com slash donate
donations of any size are much
appreciated